[Music]
back when we thought the prequels would
be the last Star Wars stuff we would
ever get thanks
I don't like sound one animators stood
against the darkness and said to hell
with making the force balanced I'm gonna
make it
Jack genndy tartakovsky Clone Wars look
we'll do the Clone Wars TV series
eventually okay it just ended for sheeps
sake gear up for the original adaptation
of the throwaway line of dialogue in a
new hole you fought in the Clone Wars
that's no longer canon because they
already replaced it because we're so
crammed full of Star Wars crap now
they're already rebooting the spin-offs
and it's a shame because even though
these animated shorts were made to
promote a movie there wasn't very good
they are totally
completely
hugely
balls to the wall
look exhausting - watching one sitting
man this is a lot of action meatballs
were a little Star Wars dialogue in
there Annie you're almost a Jedi Knight
and then and then what Jedi's aren't
supposed to be married never mind let's
just get the lightsabers ruling again oh
yeah that's the stuff all the Jedi you
love are back
Anakin is somehow even one year but I am
the best pilot in the order Chancellor
Palpatine knows it I don't know why you
can't spatter on obi-wan is a real piece
of sass seems I've created quite the
mess now haven't I wasn't incredible
smell you've discovered sand Jackson is
probably pissed off he voiced this Clone
Wars mace windu this is the dark day for
the Republic instead of this Clone Wars
mace windu and Yoda is doing his best
ren and stimpy impression
[Music]
[Applause]
Palpatine idiot you are together they'll
lead an army of clones against hordes of
killer droids using a wide range of
tactics like charging straight into them
at full speed
and nope that's it
and the Jedi were bad generals the
clones would order 66 time with her
without Palpatine return to a time when
the darkside was gathering its forces
but she wasn't ready to make a move yet
which means these Clone Wars are chocked
full of Dooku a villain destined to
train bad guys who are way cooler than
he is like this unnamed murder lady a
for Caesar so badass she got a name in
the reboot general grievous an
unstoppable combination of Michael Myers
and a Dustbuster and a collection of
supercool randos you'll get pissed off
you never got an action figure of I mean
seriously nute Gunray is a toy but we
didn't get Hells Angel jousting droid
what about third active Akira guy where
is my articulated wolf man Jedi
so strap in as your favorite sci-fi riff
on old samurai movies gets ripped on by
a guy famous for his sci-fi samurai
cartoon and by rift on I mean he just
did a long samurai jack episode with
lightsabers that kept Star Wars alive
after the prequels inspired your
favorite stuff about the new Canon and
gave us the best ending in the Star Wars
franchise Anakin getting tribal tats
from a space league while they talk
about entering a mom's mouth to say the
Navi II answers a mother's mouth to
awaken in a flame what story
My Little Pony magic friendship is you
have his coordinates and plug them in
hyperspace tracking man last year I run
this movie too like Spencer Moon died
these squid guys have a dong and balls
in the back of their heads it flops in
everything
c3 peep show
[Music]
impressive yes I probably can see it
myself and dramatic cloak work
star shorts his Anakin eating bugs a
thing did they just make that up or does
he canonically slurp down worms for fun
in a world where world wars are hurled
hurdles for curled curdles and twirled
Turtles Cowabunga dude II if poison
finishes its expiry date this has become
less poisonous or more poisonous of
course I want a lot I love the way you
make them